DISEASE.
IN ADDITION WE HAVE ANOTHER
STUDY COMBINING THIS WITH AN
ANTI-INFLAMMATORY AGENTS.
NEXT, WE HAVE VACCINES AT
SEVERAL HAVE MENTIONED IT’S
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT TO HAVE SAFE
AND EFFECTIVE VACCINES AVAILABLE
FOR EVERYONE IN THIS COUNTRY AS
WELL AS GLOBALLY.
IN THAT REGARD WE PUT TOGETHER
MYSELF AND SOME OF MY COLLEAGUES
AND PUBLISHED IN "SCIENCE"
MAGAZINE A FEW WEEKS AGO BUT WE
CALL THE STRATEGIC APPROACH TO
CORONAVIRUS 19 VACCINE AND A
DEVELOPMENT.
IT’S NOT THAT COMPREHENSIVE PLAN
BUT IT IS A STRONG PLAN
REGARDING THE RESEARCH.
IT’S IN THE TRIAL OF VARIOUS
STAGES, AND THAT’S MULTIPLE
CANDIDATES IN COUNTRIES.
AND PARAMETERS THAT ARE BEING
FUNDED AND ARE BEING PURSUED.
AND OTHERS WILL BE STAGGERED
ALONG THE WAY IN THE BLOOD OF
THE SUMMER IN THE END OF THE
SUMMER OR EARLY ON.
THERE IS THE EARLY CLEAR
PRELIMINARY DATA THAT WE WILL AT
LEAST KNOW THE EXTENT OF
EFFICACY THROUGH THE WINTER AND